prince harry opening up about entering a
therapy to deal with his mom's death
twenty years after she passed I can
safely say that losing my mom at the age
of twelve and therefore shutting down
all of my emotions for the last twenty
years has had a a quite serious effect
on on not only my personal life but also
my work as well my way of dealing with
it was yeah sticking my head in the sand
refusing to ever think about my mum
because why would that help it's only
gonna make you sad it's not gonna bring
her back Harry tells the Telegraph's new
podcast mad world that he's been in
treatment for the past couple of years
to unpack issues he never dealt with he
adds that finally dealing with his grief
is the best thing he's ever done next do
you say children that you know now
you're in that could place of course I
would love to I would love to have kids
Harry also says working with the mental
health charity he his brother and
sister-in-law Kate started heads
together has also been a big help
[Music]